hello everyone i'm alana welcome to my
channel where you are just about to
watch
some of the most chaotic halo gameplay
of my entire life
but first i have dawned so much
look at it just so much put a finger
apparel
look basically because m ad read time
they have this cool collaboration with
halo and xbox where okay part one
you can enter daily in the butterfinger
sweepstakes at game with
butterfinger.com for the chance to win
an xbox
series x but also there is more
basically if you buy two bars
watch out you can collect up to four
exclusive
uh halo infinite player emblems like
this other way
every time like this and this
and probably also this if i can
edit correctly there'll be a link in my
description where you guys can get more
information and you can enter to win
the xbox series x at
gamewithbutterfinger.com like it says
on the merch see to
the video the problem is the problem is
that we've all been playing halo and
drinking for like let me check my
first five hours oh isn't it crazy how
every year well i was i haven't even
moved yet jesus
control's not working i'm panicked i'm
shook
come on bud does this map just take you
back to those times where your friends
are like oh we thought you didn't want
to come
i will say i'm very grateful that that
tony and i were both into video games so
it was kind of like
like built-in person to play games with
yeah same as my sister my sister and i
played
co-op games like my whole life but she
doesn't play games anymore it's
devastating
he just beats me up and calls me a nud
like wedgies and
no edge not wedgies not this far
in you can get arrested for wedgies
and there's no in between oh
my gosh there's too many of them
there's too many of you it's too many of
you the shot is not that useful
okay i'll take it jakey's gone we got
this
don't forget to play careful they're
they're they're being i'm probably on
the left side
i'm not doing that right oh i just got
sniped in one shot well you're not being
careful dude come on
i was i was but
i might be bouncing i i know wants to
wants to join in but i might have to get
all because i think i had to wake up
early
okay but could you do this to us i know
i know okay chris but here's
here's here's the thing chris is that i
think i disagree
[Laughter]
yeah what's up i'm talking 2021
plan okay check this out check this out
i'm talking i'm listening lan party i'm
talking
applebee's i'm talking endless shots i'm
talking mozzarella sticks i'm talking um
360 controller in my hand wired of
course i haven't got double
a's
um i got the basic xbox 360. it doesn't
have the silver disk drive it has the
white one
what kind of face plate you got though
what kind of face plate did you pop out
the white one did you replace it with
the halo one
nos energy drink yeah
[Laughter]
can i call tomorrow and maybe we could
get a lane oh
yeah someone in my chat said applebee's
is the mcdonald's of restaurants is that
fair
now
by the way still unclear on what it is
but being honest
have you ever been to a chili no ah
well i can't i think like the one thing
about being foreign that doesn't
really get any easier is uh chains and
food brands but i'm still not clear on
what kind of food it is is it burgundy
it's like american yeah it's like
burgers america it's just like americans
grow food it's like america it's like
fries burgers kind of
the thing is it's fries burgers but then
on top of it they have regular items
that try to be
like around the world where they'll be
like we have
like uh calamari like fettuccine that's
so exotic
calamari
they have cheap drinks and they have
good appetite i love treat trains
that's what i'm talking about trip drink
like
back into the swing of things kind of
get out of here [ __ ]
oh i did get him i got him great can i
ask
not for fast food but sit down
restaurant what's the most heinous crime
that like australia has for a sit-down
restaurant well i feel like it's sizzler
we just don't have that many chains
never been to a sizzler but i've heard
about sizzler
man because australia is not like as
capitalist as corporate america
like we just don't have that many chains
bro
genuinely though we don't sometimes but
i look i don't i look
five years older than ethan so yeah he
does look like a sweet little baby also
i met him
not even legally able to drink yet and
it's also not
just against ethan but it's the fact
that i look like a middle-aged
man when i'm also 24 i'm about to be 24.
it's the mustache man
yeah no it really is because before i
look i mean i don't think you
i don't think you look that old in the
face but the mustache does make you look
like a pedophile regardless
if the shoe fits
oh no this is too many of them oh no
come on yes
our last game will be the flag
capture the fly yes we'll do two more
speaking straight facts guys i trust her
she's worked for major publications i've
mentioned
we listen to her play two games you know
that's all like at least
two at least two at least that's how i
got the job at ig and i was like bro did
you know that i played two [ __ ] games
at halo and they were like [ __ ] that's
sick
and i was there for three years you
showed up
oh wow okay okay i'm uncomfortable
wow it's like we're on roller skates
yeah yeah it's jet set radio future nice
good reference
unlike sunset overdrive which is
actually quite slow
[Laughter]
i deserve that i'm just trying to get an
energy sword kill you would you stay
still
just stay still ethan thank you [ __ ] he
stayed still
the nerve this is so ridiculous this
isn't
it's nuts this is the [ __ ] i love i love
it yeah i'm a fan
but it's [ __ ] stupid yeah no
i basically got an xbox at the tail end
of halo 3
and i got to play it for like a few
months and then halo reach came out
so i mean halo reach is also
quite good as it turns out i love
everything so sorry guys my favorite is
halo 2 and then halo reach
like those i respect that i played the
most of reach online even though i
wouldn't say it's my favorite i just
played the most of it yeah i think i was
in the same boat as you
because i played so much of the forge of
it even too
i think i'm gonna get in the wraith
let's see how this goes
yeah sometimes you just gotta [ __ ]
around and get in a wraith man it's
gonna be really jarring to go from
from this to uh regular speed i know
oh that feels good i didn't realize our
lead oh my god yeah
should we slow down yeah he's there here
what if we
okay okay here's the thing what if we
make ethan the last fall
okay okay okay all right he's he's in
there
um climbing up the hill i don't know how
to like actually describe where he is
okay he's never like that ethan we could
only kill you
don't kill anybody yeah okay okay uh i'm
on him if you can find me oh
okay i found you someone killed me uh
ethan was was right there but he could
be anywhere now
game two speedy i'm being what's his
will okay okay i found him again he
could be anywhere
where is he uh i think he's over this
side
oh there he is there he is he's in the
middle jacob
there he is found him found him found
him found him oh
did were they all ethan kills though
jacob's not
jacob's on our team but he's on our
channel
let's just uh let's just cash out on
valhalla
or mongoose only valhalla okay pistols
only mongoose only
um elites only everywhere you guys think
the fair teams are for the final round
oh wait hold on wait blue team isn't
going anywhere
it's all about communication i can't
even find these guys
no i mean they're around i'm just upset
with him how slow i'm walking
i'm currently on the right they're
seeing me they're all centered [ __ ]
i'm coming i'm coming all right i got it
with me
i got him don't worry they're gonna get
[ __ ] up in this game it's not even
jacob go off the lift i see jacob in the
[ __ ]
he's not nice i don't know why jacob
isn't going off the left he's just kind
of running around yeah
he's running into the middle buddy of
playing for the team
he's playing for them he's playing for
them kill him
that's [ __ ] up jacob go off he's
dropping it there that's [ __ ] dumb
you son of a [ __ ] stupid goddamn
assault rifle i don't play
halo to be disrespected like this you
know yeah
ugh it's borderline out of control yeah
it's just simple there's a time limit
remaining i will play hard d if i have
to i don't play halo to be disrespected
i played destiny to be disrespected
will's dead i'm gonna die somebody else
is shooting me
someone else do you guys have uh the
other flat like the
okay cool we got it we got it tears
who's dead
come on [ __ ] it
did you get it did we get it
okay if we want to we can just play
defense for three
three three and a half minutes but let's
also not
let's also go forward i'm gonna grab a
new i'm gonna do it i'm not
trying to look like a congressman right
there okay guys i'm gonna i'm in this
banshee i'm gonna go straight there i'm
gonna jump out i'm gonna grab the flag
and i'm just gonna go hell yeah dude
that's sick
he got sick okay i jumped out too early
i'm about to get killed
excellent okay i take it back not that
sick turns out oh yeah i forgot that
when you're jumping out of vanity it
slows itself down
like half speed oh yeah it's just trying
to be considerate
yeah it's like advanced safety features
that the covenant had
didn't want any losses they've got a
banshee now oh yeah my bad they have two
banshees now because
hey great work oh they are all really
proud of you
here wait a minute all right let's go
but i don't think any of them are at
their base right so
okay what if i grab the flag and then
can i get in the water there's someone
here
oh [ __ ] tony's dead in that banshee
because of chris
okay where's jake get [ __ ] he's in the
back he's running up to the left side
for you guys
okay i'm in i have that flag and i'm
running
so slowly yes okay i'll get over there
i'll try and get over there
oh they're trying to attack okay then
i'll use the wraith to defend
they're russian how are they not coming
for me
i feel like there should be dramatic
music playing oh you probably shouldn't
run that way it looks like they're
trying to push that way okay pushing
right no there's there's too many
they're like right [ __ ] next to me oh
never mind yeah you're gonna get [ __ ]
up
actually no it looks like it's just
about i just killed jakey i'm trying man
i'm out here with the flight i'm
dead in the wraith i'm dead in the radio
jesus right here he just killed himself
oh my god he's dead focus on the flag
focus on the flag
oh come on come on respawning [ __ ]
[ __ ] help pow pow-pow help
we got this we gotta go please please
help please help keep going keep going
keep going
we got it we got it we uh we totally
have it guys i'll hold the line up here
chris do you go with lana yeah yeah it's
strategic
we got it we got it we just run away we
are already done we're already done why
is this stupid game so slow
we already got it
what the [ __ ] chris wait this was that
was yeah
it literally said chris ray gun betrayed
you
all right
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what's happening
[ __ ] hell man oh
it's right there jacob he's portraying
us
hey here we go there we go
oh my okay here we go